today I want to share with you one of
the only feasible methods that I know of
for Escaping The Rat Race part one step
number one understand that the system is
broken it is virtually impossible for
you to Simply work hard reduce your
costs and save your way out of the Rat
Race step number two increase your
income stream the more money you have
the more money you can potentially make
If this means that you need to stay at
your current job that's fine because
right now in this current economy more
important than ever you need that stream
of income to keep coming in and the
larger the stream is the better as it
will give you more chances to actually
make it out of the Rat Race step number
three take asymmetrical bets an
asymmetrical bet is a bet that has
limited downside with almost unlimited
upside which basically means that it's a
bet that has a decent chance of paying
off extraordinarily High Returns the key
part here is a decent chance of paying
off follow us for more helpful tips